there are many people you'll talk to in
your lifetime many people on a daily
basis so many people family girlfriend
boyfriend husband so many different
people you'll talk to but the most
important and the most difficult person
you will ever talk to is a man in the
mirror or the woman in the middle this
is a very tough conversation you know
why because imagine you go up against an
attorney that has access to every single
information on you how do you win that
case how do you win that argument you
can't lie he has proof of everything she
has proof of everything that's this
person if you can beat this attorney you
can have a great life if you can't beat
this attorney you're gonna have a tough
life because they're gonna prove you
wrong if we try to lie or hide behind
something that you don't know about but
the question comes back to you how do
you talk to the man or the woman the
mirror what do you tell them how often
you talk to them this is a conversation
to have every single day every single
day I come home and I ask myself I say
Pat how was your day did you give
everything did you push hard did you
close hard did you went after the last
sale did you challenge the people did
you challenge yourself did you work a
little harder than today did you read a
little bit more did you feed your mind
did you wake up a little bit earlier did
you make all the excuses in or did you
overcome all the odds did you do it
today and if you can win here you can
win any other place in your life in 2017
will be the beginning of the greatest
years of your life if you can win the
conversation with the man or the woman
in the mirror
[Music]